it's lit I see what you're doing over
here p12 us youth hey guys
so Burger King just dropped it's all new
flamin hot Matthew Cheetos it sounds
spicy and delicious so I'm going to go
ahead and grab some from my co-workers
at R I hope you like it let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
I [ __ ] love mac and cheese I [ __ ]
love macaroni and cheese from Wisconsin
and we eat a lot of cheese we make a lot
of mac and cheese my mom always makes me
a home-cooked mac and cheese I feel like
there's a divide between people who love
Cheetos and people who love hot cheetos
and I'm definitely on the Hot Cheetos
I [ __ ] love Cheetos I also [ __ ]
love she knows especially hot cheetos I
don't feel like I fully get like the
flaming hot cheetos crazy I used to
working as a kid a lot so it has a
special place in my heart I'm going in
with like not high hopes but like hopes
some hopes contraption I'm a little
scared they look kind of deadly they are
so red literally shaped like Cheetos
which I don't know what I was expecting
but not that it looks like a little
sausage like a mutated mozzarella stick
it smells like you're gonna have to use
the bathroom
I don't smell cheeto and I don't smell
macaroni cheese oh my god don't chase
the cheeto I thought it'd be spicier
they're spicy but they're not Hot
Cheetos spicy the spice is [ __ ] good
it's definitely like melts in your mouth
a little bit initially you get like a
nice crunch but then it goes into mush I
got all cheese no cheeto one piece of
macaroni I think this is definitely
catering to those who are really drunk
or really high maybe I'd like them more
at 3 a.m. there's just like the perfect
amount of spice the perfect amount of
mac
I love it I'm a huge fan would go buy
these after work I don't like these but
someone out there who likes Burger King
will probably enjoy these your hot
cheetos lover your mac and cheese lover
try it
and there you have it
[Music]